wait
we haven't done this one already you
sure weird
[Music]
before these movies were about secret
agents fighting space crime or whatever
damn
they got a magnet plane return to the
nuts and bolts of the fast
saga stealing dvd players
is it a panasonic pvm 939 sick
they're gonna make like a hundred bucks
the first
fast and furious movie the one with all
the thus in it
remember point break well some
screenwriter did and figured if they
changed all the surfboards into toyotas
no one would notice
now the franchise that would one day
become the mcu with a ged
goes back to its humble roots as an
educational series about car parts
i lengthened the injected pulse it's
your fuel map it's got a nasty hull
see a cool air intake and a t4 turbo
dominic
you see an aic controller direct fork
granny fishing not double clutching like
you should now me and the mad scientist
got to rip apart the block
and replace the piston ring nitrous
injection four core intercoolers ball
bearing turbos
and titanium valve springs look buddy
i'm not here to read the manual can you
make my sign look like an angry robot
penis or not
witness the birth of the movies that
have always been about family
even though half the original cast has
been disowned way to turn down half a
meal for the sequel jaw
cuda shooter luda but the keepers were
all there from the start
like brian o'connor the most obvious cop
ever
snowman right here man so it's a good
thing he's a stone cold cutie pie
because when you're done i'm putting you
on the street where you belong cutie
he's beautiful i like his haircut he's
on a dangerous undercover mission
to infiltrate dominic coretto's sister
at the center of this early artie's
underworld
is human gravel mound vin diesel let's
go for a little ride
a star with such unique charms he's made
a side career out of playing barely
alive creatures who can only grant a
single word
but here he's dom toretto the ex-con
who runs a cool tank top club for
wayward youth dom lives his life a
quarter mile at a time
because if he thought ahead any longer
he might wonder wait why do i rob trucks
at full speed with harpoons
why i'll just make him pull over first
or should i drive for a living given
what happened to my dad
clipped his bumper and put him in the
wall 120.
i watched my dad burn to death or like
i've already stolen six million dollars
where of dvd players but i'll just
retire and play with my street sharks
head shark
return to a pre-gentrification los
angeles where the only thing going on at
coachella was truck heists
114 outside coachella that gathers every
stereotype in the city
to race through la's trademark traffic
free streets and shows off all the
candy-colored import cars of a 15 year
old's dreams
because while a ferrari is well out of
your average kid's reach this film got
every mouth breather to put a new
exhaust on their civic and rear end
someone because they were playing snake
on their nokia
i know i did so after 20 years
nine movies and a universal studios ride
that made ven diesel the same size
as a helicopter returned to a simpler
time
when the franchise wasn't trying to
outstun tom cruise the cast could all be
in the same room together
and all anyone cared about was finding
new and exciting ways to say
nos
you're lucky that 100 shot of nas didn't
blow the welds on the intake and he
ordered three
t-66 turbos with nos
starring the following car puns as is
tradition
baby driver gran turetto kia
hot rodriguez carlo santana
jesse pinkslip johnny transmission
jawru presents tire festival and
hello spoilers car wars
rise of paul walker
have they just not ironed out the
details of their corona deal yet or what
are the fast and furious movies actually
good i can't even tell anymore
we settle whether the franchise is sick
bro or sucks yo
in a new video called love it or hate it
click the thumbnail on the right
the missions change they always do
barnaby put the potato down